hello belief nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems I
started to mentor me series with the
goal to try to learn from people who've
done a lot more than as people who have
done amazing things that by spending a
little bit more time with them hopefully
some of their values their belief
systems their way of thinking seeped
into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so to help you on
your journey today we're going to learn
from Brendon Burchard and some of his
best advice on motivation mentor me
Brendon rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys when you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself to enjoy
[Music]
Oh
why is this sometimes you're so
motivated and driven you're excited to
go and do something in other days you
can't tear yourself off the couch away
from the fifth season of Netflix what's
the difference why is that some people
are so much more successful because they
have that that drive that hunger that
ambition that clarity and others
struggle over and over and over to get
ahead the whole thing comes down to as
you know motivation but most people
don't know where motivation really comes
from and and we think hopefully one day
we'll just have motivation you know
we'll wake up and be motivated but my
favorite metaphor to teach people is
this one the power plant doesn't have
energy it generates energy in the same
way we don't have motivation we generate
motivation and once you understand the
science of motivation when you
understand where motivation actually
comes from now you know how to cultivate
it and grow it and that's where I spent
the last 20 years of my life researching
and studying the first thing that sparks
motivation is ambition ambition is that
desire for something more I know that's
so simple but hold on a second because
most people's ambition is set too low
for themselves they've settled down on
their ambition because one time they
were disappointed one time somebody made
fun of them maybe their spouse their
partner their girlfriend their boyfriend
somebody around them doesn't support
them and cheer them on when they have
ideas and so now there are ambitions and
the major areas of their life are
actually pretty low and if I can tell
anybody anything to get more motivation
first get more ambition dream again my
friend be okay that your dreams in your
vision for yourself for your emotional
reality for your for your health for
your finances for how much money you
have for what you contribute to the
world you have to dream of that again
you have to lay awake in bed and think
about what you desire and want and not
just on New Year's once a year every
single day think what I really desire
what do I really want your ambitions
must stay in front of you to keep that
way
chain of motivation going never lose
hope that that you have a single breath
in your body right now and that you are
alive in this moment is hope that you
can see all these people walking on the
streets smiling is is hope that all
these entrepreneurs are posting their
art online every single day now there is
hope there that there's a single person
out in this world whose soul is still
burning alive with love is hope you know
it's so easy during these days when
sometimes there's darkness when you see
all this negative media coverage or
maybe you have a series of bad days or
series of bad weeks or you're your lucky
break just isn't coming or even fighting
for that dream you just don't sense any
of that progress that you just so need
to feel still enliven and engage and
enthusiastic about something or somebody
breaks up with you or you lose your job
or something happens with your health
look that's part of life is there's
going to be so many struggles and
disappointment challenges setbacks dark
days and part of sustaining and making
through all of that is maintaining hope
and that hope isn't something that just
you know some airy-fairy concept it is a
psychological need to believe that we
can endure a psychological need to
believe that we can not only endure but
we can succeed and we can thrive and we
can have our way in the world so that we
can accomplish our dream so that we can
make influence if you make our own
difference to have hope we have to stay
persistent persistent you know to keep
at it no matter what you know if we've
got our perspective in mind we've got
our plan we've got to be persistent to
keep working towards it you know there
were so many times that I almost stopped
doing these videos there are so many
times that I thought well I'm not going
to write another book there's so many
times I thought no one cares about my
blog post no one cares about my Facebook
post no one cares about my youtube show
no one cares about me oh woe is me look
we can all sit on the couch eat a bunch
of potato chips watch stupid television
to feel sorry for ourselves that does
not contribute to our lives in this it
does not contribute to our connection
with those we love and care for
and it does not contribute to the things
that we create and ultimately give to
the world so we've got to say you know
what this is not what what are we going
to persist at sitting in eating potato
chips and watching TV that's not going
to be good what we have to do is persist
towards our dream what are the three
things you could accomplish yet this day
this very day and tomorrow and start
moving towards your dreams every day
wake up with an intention I'm going to
do at least three things to move myself
forward to something that matters at
least three things everybody can do that
just pick what are the three things I'm
going to do to move my life forward this
day who would I need to reach out to to
be able to move forward what can I read
or study online to move forward what
could I do just one simple request one
simple movement wants to pull step to
move forward and persist at that over
and over and over again and that's how
things change what is it that's going to
actually change somebody's life it's not
removing their limiting beliefs and I
know that sounds silly but it's like
just if you just put less pressure on
the break in your car it doesn't mean
you're going to speed up right your foot
still on the brake if you're always
focusing on these things that are
limiting you you're always going to be
limited just because your relative
weight of importance and duration of
your focus and your attention is on
these limiting things and it's a time in
our culture just like in our psychology
in our study of psychology we got to
move from mental illness to mental
health we've got to get you to move from
your limiting beliefs into something
bigger and greater and grand about
yourself we've got to stop you focusing
on all the reasons that you're a mouse
in life and start focusing on why you're
a lion why you have something within you
that's more bold and powerful profound
than you ever even knew so what we have
to do is change what I call your
dominant frame of attention and focus
most people's dominant frame they're
given that relative weight of importance
to those things that limit them and I
said you know what this year this next
year has to be the year for you that
your limitless that you're going to go
okay you know enough I mean how far have
you gotten in your life now where you're
just constantly beating yourself and
berating
and worrying about your limits and
worrying about all these things of all
the reasons that you have to be worried
to be weak to be less than you are
there's like a marianne williamson said
so long ago you're not serving the world
by playing small and you're not serving
the world by constantly focusing on your
limiting briefs and trying to remove
them look you will always have
insecurities I know that's really
motivating but you're always going to
have it I work with some of the top
professionals in every given field
some of the best athletes in the world
so the best well known celebrities and
many of the people who are the best
performers in any given industry and I
can tell you they still have their
doubts and their fears they still have
times when they wake up and they're just
like I don't know to do with myself that
doesn't ever go away and that's great
because it's part of the human condition
that also makes us humble makes us real
makes us check ourselves and I'm not
saying that you know we all have to go
around being happy optimists all the
time but I will share you with you if
you didn't know optimists are much more
capable of change in the world than
pessimists are it's not a guess it's
proven by science and what do we mean by
that optimism is one of the most studied
thing in the psychology literature
period it's one of most studied traits
optimists are more likely to face a
problem than pessimists because
pessimists go oh I can't change it I
can't do anything about it it's going to
be that way forever
it's pervasive problem and I don't have
a control of it an optimist says well I
could probably handle that we can change
that too
in other words pessimists tend to avoid
problems that need to be changed and
optimists tend to confront them and move
forward and do something about it that's
pretty profound and it's pretty proven
now so yeah I'm saying you know while
not all of us can go around being
happy-go-lucky and avoiding all of our
limits I'm also saying you know what
maybe it is time that we focus on those
things that we can change focus on
something that's bigger than ourselves
and our own little insecurities and
worries and I think that's the challenge
right now with so many people saying
limiting beliefs limiting beliefs look
they're there you're going to have them
the question is are they going to win
the day your peers have a lot to do with
the setting long term of
your health of your Drive of your
success of your socioeconomic status the
people that you hang out with impact
your life tremendously
so your environment do you have the
right people if you don't have great
people around you I was tell people go
to a seminar get in personal development
go volunteer go to do stings with your
church group but just get out there with
people who are like-minded who want to
grow and want to give because if you're
around people who want to grow and give
all day long you become stronger and you
contribute more to and suddenly you find
more motivation and fulfillment here's a
very simple thing you can do to
reprogram your mind create a sheet of
two simple things very simple things I
want you to write five questions down
that you're going to ask yourself three
or four times a day five questions that
are positive for yourself to do every
day you're going to wake up in the
morning you're going to read these
questions to yourself you're gonna
answer them you're going to read them
you're going to answer them every
morning then at lunch read the questions
answer them at night read the questions
answer these many questions like what
can I feel incredibly grateful for right
now how could I surprise or flirt with
somebody right now how could I have fun
right now positive things like that
right how could I demonstrate love or
excellence right now ask these questions
the morning ask them the afternoon ask
them at night by asking these positive
questions over and over I mean you just
do this for 30 days you're going to
recognize a total shift in your life
just simple questions but you're giving
them weight by focusing on three times
during the day you're having duration by
focusing on it three times during a day
over 30 days your mind starts to reshift
its gears to give automatic ease to
answering those questions and living in
that mindset versus an undirected
unconscious mindset second thing on that
sheet or those things you can do five
questions first second thing I want to
do is come up three words that describe
your ideal self just three words you
know minor for example present excited
and bold so I'm going to focus on those
questions three times a day as well what
I do is I put them on my iPhone and they
come up as an alarm three different
times during
my phone buzzes and those words are
there like oh right I'm that guy
I got focused on being that guy versus
whatever I might be in a bad mood ah you
know it's completely detach and then I
look I'm like dude I know I'm an excited
person get great that thought get back
into this got it this is who I am and
now that might sound so simply simple
simpie Sippy's it's like sounds so
simple but guess what people won't do
the discipline they are so frustrated
with their mind because they haven't
done the conscious discipline to
reprogram it the first idea is to
emotionally engage with that dream each
morning of your life see a lot of people
don't actually struggle with the
discipline part in terms of the doing
the thing it's that they are not getting
revved up to do the thing in other words
we got a problem with motivation not
necessarily just discipline we have a
problem with that once in a while you
hit it you do it you do the work but a
lot of times you fall off because you're
not emotionally engaged in it it's like
if you want a lot of discipline you need
a high level of emotional connection and
focus on that thing that you want to
work towards so every morning what I
want you to do is just start a new
visualization practice when you wake up
in the morning close your eyes think
about the dream the aspiration the thing
that you're really after in life and
just visualize it and really get
yourself emotionally attached
emotionally engage with it think about
how great it will feel for you to have
that thing or be that thing or
contribute that thing to make that
difference just think about it allow it
to well up in your heart a little bit
get excited about it remember the dream
that's why we get away from discipline
because we're so busy with the chaos to
the world that we emotionally are no
longer attached in a way that our brain
says hey man focus on this it's
important to you remember so if your
heart is disengaged it's difficult to
stay disciplined
so every morning make it a practice to
actually just imagine the payoff the
benefit the contribution the art the
thing that you do and are doing and do
contribute if you can do that more often
you'll be more fired up and you'll save
back on track you have to actually show
up every day and into yourself forward
toward these dreams and not only show up
every day and once in a while into
yourself I mean every day you have to
actually take an action that moves you
forward not just research not just
thinking look the power of an intention
is great but without any initiative it's
dead right a dream is great but without
any movement it's dead you have to be
moving towards everyday you can send an
email every day you can make a call
every day you can write something every
day you can create something every day
you can contribute something every day
but it has to be daily otherwise it will
never become actualized and the highest
performers in the world didn't get there
because they were lucky they worked at
it longer than everyone else
they had a better work ethic and it's
not that many necessarily always worked
harder they work smarter because they
were doing the research they were taking
the time to visualize how they would be
distinct different how they would
survive the tough times they really kept
at it keep every single day momentum
going and if you don't do that there's
no chance in the psychology literature
expectancy means it's it's a belief that
not only is it possible for you but that
you can do it that you have the personal
control the self-reliance the autonomy
that the thing that says you know what I
believe in my ability to figure this out
and I know I can move the needle of
progress forward in going this in others
you expect your dreams to happen and you
expect that you have the strength and
the confidence to make it happen the
challenge is I know so many people in
the world who sometimes they have the
dream but the ambition goes away because
of other people around them sometimes
they have the ambition and the dream but
they don't really believe in them
beep down inside thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video that you're going to immediately
apply somehow to your life or to your
business leave it down the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also wanted to give a quick shout it to
Oscar and demo Oscar thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and doing the review on your
YouTube channel I really really
appreciate it man and I'm so glad that
you enjoy the book
today's book book report is the one word
by Evan Carmichael thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon